1000 flüchtlinge jeden tag das ist keine
warnung das ist realität jetzt bei uns
1000 flüchtlinge jeden tag von belarus
diktator zu uns nach europa durch
geschickt von herrn lukaschenko und noch
innenminister horst seehofer hat jetzt
alarm geschlagen bei uns bei bild live
was kann er noch tun als scheidender nur
noch geschäftsführender innenminister
was muss er jetzt tun bei uns im studio
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer guten
morgen ja was kann was muss horst
seehofer noch endlich tun also horst
seehofer war gestern hier im studio
stand ein paar meter weiter und hat ja
auch angeboten einen gipfel zu
veranstalten hat den chefs der drei
ampel parteien ja auch die hand gereicht
es gibt zwei dinge die jetzt wichtig
sind es muss einen flüchtlings gipfel
auf europäischer ebene geben das ist
ganz klar denn das ist ja nicht nur eine
krise und diese flüchtlingskrise ist
zurück mit voller wucht die jetzt polen
und deutschland betrifft die betrifft am
ende die gesamte europäische union hier
wird brede kriegsführung von seiten aus
weißrussland und aus russland gegenüber
der union betrieben und der zweite punkt
ist das sind natürlich jetzt auch die
flüchtlinge von olaf scholz christian
lindner und annalena baerbock das muss
man ganz klar so sagen diese drei sind
dabei eine neue regierung für
deutschland zu zimmern zusammenzubauen
und die können sich jetzt nicht
wegducken sondern sie müssten jetzt
eigentlich schon klar sagen idealerweise
einen neuen innenminister benennen das
ist schwer das weiß ich aber das wäre
das beste um genau dieser krise jetzt
schon mit viel viel tatendrang und kraft
herr zu werden jetzt ist man in so einer
grauzone die neue regierung ist nicht
installiert die koalitionsverhandlungen
laufen horst seehofer hat gestern seine
abschieds urkunde erhalten und jetzt
wird es ja auch noch einige wochen so
weitergehen was glaubst du wie
handlungsfähig ist man da im moment
überhaupt das genau der kern des
problems natürlich ist horst seehofer
nicht mehr so handlungsfähig wie noch
vor der bundestagswahl genau das ist das
problem und deswegen muss es eigentlich
von seiten der ampel
koalitionspartner jetzt schon deutliche
signale geben zum einen wie man damit
umgehen möchte mit dieser
flüchtlingskrise und ich weiß es kommt
aus dem reich der wünsche jetzt schon
jemanden zu benennen der als möglicher
nächster innenminister dann auftritt
damit der schon eigentlich der lage ist
diese krise die wir sehen schon zu
managen am besten mit horst seehofer
zusammen bis er dann insgesamt die
ernennungsurkunde erhält und dann
alleiniger chef des innenministeriums
ist stichwort mauern gegen flüchtlinge
hier in deutschland so ausdruck großer
empörung sofort in polen hat das große
unterstützung die betreiben das ja auch
bereits und jetzt gewinnt ist aber nach
und nach aus sympathie hier in
deutschland beispielsweise bei sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmann michael
kretschmer bauern gegen flüchtlinge kann
das eine lösung sein auch für die
deutsche politik also alles klar europa
und das ist auch immer wieder debattiert
worden aber nie richtig umgesetzt worden
braucht natürlich sehr sehr gut bewachte
außengrenzen das ist doch ganz logisch
wir sind ein ort eine große region für
viele ein paradies die hierher kommen
wollen und zwar nicht weil sie asyl
mäßig verfolgt werden ihren
heimatländern sondern weil sie hier
gerne leben möchten aus verständlichen
gründen aber das geht natürlich nicht
weil nicht jeder mensch der welt in
europa leben kann das funktioniert nicht
aber wir haben ein asylrecht und das
gilt auch und für diese menschen muss
hier in europa platz sein aber nicht für
diejenigen die aus beispielsweise
wirtschaftlichen gründen kommen und
einfach sagen ja es liebt sich hier
schöner als bei mir zuhause für die es
kein platz und ob das jetzt eine mauer
an den grenzen ist oder ob das einfach
extrem harter grenzschutz ist wie man
das dann auch bezeichnen wird das ist
glaube ich egal entscheidend ist dass
diese außengrenzen die europäischen
extrem gut gesichert sind